[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: Typically, the
goal of machine learning
is to generalize
about a set of data.
However, sometimes it's
possible to recover
information about
specific training examples
from a trained model.
How can we provide
more privacy and ensure
our models capture general
patterns, rather than
specific examples?
Stay tuned to find out.
Welcome to AI Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode,
we're going to take a look
at TensorFlow Privacy,
a new tool aimed at making
it easy to train models
with privacy.
Last year, Google published a
set of responsible AI practices
focused around fairness,
interpretability, privacy,
and security.
One of the recommended
practices in the Privacy section
states, "Appropriately safeguard
the privacy of ML models,"
and recommends that we
train ML models using
techniques that establish
mathematical guarantees
for privacy.
This is all well and
good to recommend,
but it does leave you wondering,
how exactly do I do that?
When you train a
machine learning model,
the goal should be to learn
these general patterns, not
facts about specific
training examples.
Otherwise the model
ends up memorizing
a set of specific facts,
which may not generalize well
to previously-unseen
data, and may
lead to possible exposure
of the underlying data that
was memorized.
This is especially important
when that data set corresponds
to user actions or
user attributes.
Of course, it's not enough to
say that your model probably
doesn't memorize
specific users' data.
What we want is
to use techniques
that offer strong mathematical
guarantees that models do not
learn or remember any details
about any specific user.
TensorFlow Privacy
does just this--
all without needing any
expertise in privacy
or understanding its
underlying mathematics.
So what's happening
under the hood?
In order to ensure that no
single example can impact
that final trained
model, TensorFlow Privacy
introduces some
modifications to the way
that gradients are calculated
during the training process.
Gradients are a way of
expressing which direction
and how far a
model should update
its internal state, represented
by weights and biases--
or put another way, a
large matrix of numbers.
And typically, during
a single training step,
we use a batch of data--
just some subset-- to
determine the gradient,
and then apply it to update
the value of the weights.
So in other words, we look
at some bit of the data,
figure out, based on
that, which direction
and how far to shift our
model, and then we go there.
TensorFlow Privacy makes
a few small but key tweaks
to how that gradient
is computed.
If a single example is
providing an outsize effect
on that model's gradient, it
may cause it to stick out,
so to speak, and
thus potentially be
exposed in the trained model.
One example of how TensorFlow
Privacy addresses this
is by averaging together
multiple mini-gradient updates
on a subset of the full batch.
So each mini-gradient's
value is clipped,
limiting its range
of possible values,
and so that restricts
their individual impact.
These mini-gradients are
then averaged together.
And finally, we add some
Gaussian random noise
on top of this average.
So by doing this, we're ensured
that no individual example
will be memorized by the model.
In practice, you don't need to
modify your model architecture
or training procedures
to take advantage
of TensorFlow Privacy.
Instead, to train models,
use a different optimizer
provided by the TensorFlow
Privacy Library,
and we'll fill in some values
to customize the optimizer's
clipping, noise level,
and number of mini-batches
to average together.
Yes, we're going to introduce
some more hyperparameters
for you to tune,
but hey, it's better
than rewiring your entire
model, and it's better
than exposing your users' data.
Now let's take a look
at an example of what
TensorFlow Privacy can achieve.
In their blog post
announcing the launch,
the team highlighted an
interesting situation
with a language
learning model which
is supposed to identify English
sentences that look like they
come from financial news.
With the two models
side by side,
one trained using TensorFlow
Privacy and one without,
there are many sentences
where both models agreed
on, say, sentences that
look like financial news,
such as, "South Korea and Japan
continue to be profitable."
But then there were the ones
which the models disagreed on.
These were notable, because
while the data set had marked
these sentences
as financial news,
they definitely don't look like
they belong in financial news.
What's interesting
here is that not only
do these anomalous
sentences account for most
of the differences in accuracy
between these two models,
but this really
illustrates the idea
that going by metrics purely is
not always the right decision.
It also suggests
that perhaps we can
utilize TensorFlow
Privacy and similar tools
to identify aspects
of a data set
which perhaps shouldn't even
be there in the first place.
TensorFlow Privacy turns
the science and math
behind differential privacy
into a tool that you can use.
And while the tuning
of hyperparameters
does remain a bit
of an art, the team
has offered up some
reasonable initial values
to begin your exploration.
For more details and examples,
head on over to the blog post
I have linked below
in the description.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures,
and if you enjoyed it
hit that Like button
and be sure to subscribe to get
all the latest episodes, right
when they come out.
For now, check out
TensorFlow Privacy
to make machine learning
safer for your users.